- Most of you are not
doing what you want to do
with your life
because you're worried
about someone else's opinion.
Normally,
your fucked up mom,
or your spouse,
or somebody very close to
you is fucking your shit up.
(audience laughter)
Right, so that's awesome
for me, but on the flip side
in the macro of
me not giving a shit
when somebody leaves one comment
on an Instagram post like,
this guy is a scam artist.
I'm like strategizing
how to fix that like
it's the most important thing
that has ever happened to me.
Pulling from opposite directions
is like a bridge, my friends.
It is not something
that you should be scared of.
Way too many people
think it's a contradiction,
think it's a flaw.
When you define what
true intelligence is,
it is holding
opposite things in your head
and allowing them to push.
I love that
everything is easy to me.
We were having fun
beforehand, I'm like,
what's this thing I'm
doing after my keynote,
and they're laughing, they're
like, you didn't read it?
I'm like, I haven't
read shit in 20 years.
I don't need to be
prepared, I stay in my lane.
The reason I love doing
Q&amp;A is if I don't know
the answer to
your question I'll say
I don't know the
answer to your question.
We are fronting, we are
fronting in our society.
You need to triple down,
quadruple down on who you are
and what you know,
and then you can win.
When people ask me
how do I produce content?
One big breakthrough in
my community was when about
six months ago I said, you
know what, you should document
instead of create.
It opened up so much for
so many when they realized,
wait a minute, right,
you need to be documenting
in your stories or in
your vlog about the journey
of becoming an entrepreneur,
not claiming that you're
a 21-year-old life coach,
and pay me $5,000 a month
and I'll teach you how
to fucking live, fuck you.
(light music)